you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
four more climate records are broken yet
another stark warning of the damage
we're doing to the planet
the global energy system is broken and
bringing us ever closer to climate
catastrophe
a new green trade strategy for the uk
but will there be any green strings
attached
and a vast expansion in renewable energy
capacity as the eu lays out its plans to
wean itself off russian fossil fuels
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
now yet another stark warning on the
health of the planet today the world
meteorological organization released its
annual state of the planet report which
laid bare the damage that we're doing
the report finds that four key climate
change indicators greenhouse gas
concentrations sea level rise ocean heat
and ocean acidification all set new
records in 2021
while the past seven years have been the
warmest on record
the average global temperature in 2021
was about 1.1 degree above
pre-industrial levels that's ever closer
to the 1.5 degree limit agreed to by
global leaders
well the u.n secretary general has once
again laid the blame clearly at the feet
of the international fossil fuel
industry
every minute of every day coal oil and
gas receive roughly 11 million us
dollars in subsidies each year
governments around the world pour around
alpha trillion dollars into artificially
lowering the price of fossil fuels more
than triple what renewables receive
while people suffer from high prices at
the pump the oil and gas industry is
raking in billions from a distorted
market
this scandal must stop
and that global debate over the role of
fossil fuels is playing out here as well
this was at prime minister's questions
today
british households are slapped with an
extra 53 million pounds on their energy
bills every single day
meanwhile every single day north sea oil
and gas giants rake in 32 million pounds
in unexpected profits we believe in jobs
and we believe in investment and we
believe in growth and as it happens the
oil companies the oil companies
concerned are on track to invest about
70 billion pounds into our economy over
the next few years they're already taxed
mr speaker at a rate of uh 40
well our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter is here with me so
hannah where are the politics on this
and what effect would a windfall tax
have on climate targets well i mean
sakia stammer leader of the labour party
there's obviously calculated that this
is an increasingly uncomfortable
position for the prime minister
labour arguing that while people are
struggling to heat their homes and feed
their families it is simply the right
thing to do to impose a one-off windfall
tax on what are essentially unearned
unexpected profits and that a u-turn on
this winterfall tax position the prime
minister is currently occupying is
inevitable and by the way he is
supported by some senior conservative
backbenchers and polling suggests the
public think it's the right thing to do
as well but the prime minister and the
business secretary
are very squeamish about imposing a
windfall tax as we just heard there
they are concerned that it might damage
the uk's reputation as a predictable
place
to do business although the
chancellorishi sunac interestingly
enough is much more open to the idea and
has suggested that if these big oil and
gas companies don't invest more in the
uk and in renewables then when full tax
might be coming their way and that
neatly leads us on to the issue of what
impact does all of this have on climate
change policy well the oil and gas
industry as a whole many within it would
like us to believe that they're going to
pay a lot of tax on these profits anyway
and that if they are given a punitive
tax actually there won't be enough money
to invest in driving the renewable
energy revolution but campaigners say
that that is tantamount to holding
action on the climate crisis hostage
that
the uk is a very good place to do
business in terms of taxation at the
moment they have a really good deal and
that these companies can't really be
trusted to do the right thing of their
own accord and so a win for tax is the
only option
hannah thank you
well the government has today announced
a green trade strategy in an exclusive
interview with sky news the
international trade secretary said that
such a plan would help starve putin's
war machine but was less clear on
whether future trade deals would depend
on climate commitments sky's ali
fortescue reports
from early net zero ambition to cop the
uk has positioned itself as a climate
leader but are we doing enough on green
trade
our deal with australia was criticized
for abandoning climate pledges
[Music]
some say we shouldn't be talking trade
with india one of the world's biggest
emitters without climate commitments
today the trade secretary has revealed a
green trade strategy and has spoken
exclusively to sky news
we'll be doing things like liberalising
uh tariffs on green goods we've done
that with australia and new zealand
through our free trade agreements of
course all the knowledge
base of all those things that sit within
uh the green agenda that we have been
leading on the uk and we've said we're
committed this year to opening trade
talks with the gulf corporation council
there's six countries three of them
don't even have net zero targets how can
any deal there be green
so again uh those are in very early
stage of discussion at the moment with
the gcc
and we'll be looking at uh what sort of
uh trade deal uh we want to bring
together and you see already in some of
the gcc countries a real understanding
that generating clean energy is
important both for them and indeed as an
export opportunity so we can't say that
net zero should be a red line for
countries that we want to do business
with so net zero is every country's
choice to set and what's so important
for me is that we make sure that we
harness the power of the uk skills uh to
help other countries to do that
but with post-brexit freedom some
believe coherence between our trade and
climate agenda has been lost if you look
to the eu's trade talks with the us for
instance the eu's making really good
progress on standards for green steel
and aluminium it's
prioritizing public procurement in in
green and green tech
and really the uk is just absent in all
of this discussion a small announcement
here today doesn't really go anywhere
near far enough to address those really
complex issues you don't accept the eu
are doing better as some people leave on
green trade than us germany has a big
industrial base where decarbonisation is
really important france is you know
ahead of the game because 70 over 70 of
their energy is nuclear so every country
has a different part to play and the uk
has been leading right from the start we
are all working together it's not a
competition we all need to try and solve
the challenges as quickly as possible
because the planet isn't waiting nearly
a quarter of global carbon emissions
relate to trade all eyes will now be on
upcoming talks with countries like india
and the gulf states to show if the uk is
really committed to dealing with climate
change in trade ali fortescue sky news
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and pollution was
responsible for one in six deaths
worldwide in 2019 according to a study
in the lancet that figure is unchanged
since 2015 meaning most countries have
done little to deal with the enormous
public health problem over 90 percent of
the 9 million pollution related deaths
occurred in low and middle income
countries
pollution remains the largest
environmental risk factor for disease
and premature death
a report in the journal nature has found
that tree deaths in north queensland
doubled between 1984 and 2019 due to
climate change
experts analyzed over 70 000 trees from
81 different species and found that tree
life expectancy is potentially halving
in the region tropical forests are
critical to the global carbon cycle so
tree deaths could affect their ability
to remove carbon from the atmosphere
the world's biggest car manufacturers
are not playing their part in reaching
climate goals according to a report by
the think tank influence map
researchers say that just two of the 12
companies analyzed are moving fast
enough towards electric vehicles to
decarbonize the transport sector the
report also accuses the companies of
lobbying to extend the life of the
combustion engine
now the eu's dependency on russian
fossil fuels has triggered an ambitious
response the european commission chief
announced today plans to invest 300
billion euros just 10 of that 300 on new
gas infrastructure to help replace
russian imports and 2 billion for oil
the rest would be for clean energy
infrastructure
we power eu will help us to save more
energy
to accelerate the phasing out of fossil
fuel
and most importantly to kick-start
investments on a new scale
so i would say this will be the speed
charging of our european green deal
well the eu plans to cut demand for
energy by reducing its consumption and
will increase its renewable energy
target to 45 by 2030. that's from its
original target set only last year of 40
so today the governments of denmark
germany the netherlands and belgium have
said that they will hugely expand
offshore wind power in the north sea by
2050 the ambition is to increase
capacity tenfold from 15 gigawatts to
150.
so let's talk about this a little bit
more joining me now is christian ibsen
from conceito a danish think tank
welcome to you now this target of 150
gigawatts by 2050 sounds pretty
ambitious but is it fast enough given
that immediate task of replacing russian
energy and also
needing to tackle climate change quickly
well it is indeed a very high ambition
for 2050 and it is actually corresponds
to what the eu commission has put out
for the eu uh to power europe europe
from the north sea in in the 2050
pathways but you have a point that you
are actually need to see action right
now and the foreign ministers the four
countries the four prime ministers
actually also today agree that they will
increase the
renewable energy from the north sea by
four times
already in 2030 so there is actually
this notion that we need to increase
fast and we need to get all the grids
and all the things ready for that so it
is a very ambitious agreement that we
have today and presumably a pretty
expensive one as well where's the money
coming from is this private money or is
it public money
well
it will be you you need to get private
money into that pension funds and so on
but you need to play a right support
public money de-risking the investments
uh
ensuring the the capacity to to to get
the grids right and all of that so it
will be a combination of that well you
said it's expensive but the alternative
is actually more expensive
to continue to rely on fossil fuels in
the years and decades to come
the uk is also expanding its offshore
wind capacity as well and these sites
are not small are they i mean is the
north sea at risk of being quite
cluttered is it hard to find the sides
when you've also got to bear in mind
shipping lanes and fishing
yeah well the north sea is a unique spot
globally actually we have a lot of wind
it's a very low uh lying uh seabed and
so on so it's very very good for for
wind out there but there's a lot of
space out there but of course it raises
a lot of dilemmas i think we need to
reshape the planning of the north sea we
need to get the ship lanes right also
other take care of nature and
biodiversity we might need to find
synergies there because there's no way
out we need to have the nausea as a
green power hub for europe if we are to
decarbonize europe and the uk
christian ibsen very interesting to talk
to you thanks very much indeed for your
time
now let's discuss some of those issues
of the day with anna markova climate
lead at the trades union congress and
tom burke from environmental think tank
e3g good evening to both of you good to
see you
so first of all green trade it sounds
like a great idea but what does it
really mean and how much will climate
policy be included in future trade deals
so tom first of all
what is
green trade what does it actually mean
and what difference can it make to
climate change do you think
well well i'm not sure either what green
trade means are there components of
trade policy that are really important
for climate change yes and one of the
ones is really we must not allow other
countries to
not fulfill global standards on climate
change while we're doing them or we'll
undercut our own competitiveness so it's
really important that we do put a red
line in uh in terms of the free trade
agreements we negotiate with other
countries i think it was right for uh
the minister to say we need to reduce
tariffs on our importing of all of the
solar panels the wind technologies that
we need in order to decarbonize our own
economy but those are really the the
really important bits of
green trade and then we've got to make
really sure that enough there's enough
trade in the
essential raw materials we'll need to uh
underpin uh the green and the
decarbonized power system
and i do agree with that do you think
that climate pledges are
very important in trade deals should
there be a red line because some people
might say there are so many other
economic challenges that we're facing at
the moment the cost of living crisis the
risk of going into recession shouldn't
some of those issues be taken into
consideration and climate perhaps
sometimes has to take a backseat
we can absolutely have climate as a
priority alongside uh labor and
environmental protections and we must do
that um if we don't bake in these
protections then uh what's um what we're
putting ourselves at risk of happening
is that um uh all these industries that
we're that we're trying to develop will
offshore their production offshore their
jobs to places where it's um easier and
to pay people less to places where it's
easier to pollute more
and then as a result you have green
trade on paper and
extremely dirty uh trade and reality so
we absolutely must bake those
protections in to protect our jobs as
well as to protect the climate
and tom do you welcome what the
trade international trade secretary is
saying today talking about wanting to
lead the way on green trade there's talk
of nearly 190 million pounds of new loan
guarantees of new jobs being created
helping heavily polluting countries like
india for example sharing expertise on
wind power i mean it sounds like heading
in the right direction does it to you
it is the right direction there's no
doubt about that but but we always
find at the moment from the government
that it talks a bigger talk than it acts
and its actions are always rather less
uh dramatic than its headlines
and and it's fine to be pointing in the
right direction but the really important
thing is the report that came out today
from the world uh metrological
organization made clear is we really are
running out of time so what we'd like
i'd like to see is is not only getting
in the right direction but moving faster
in that direction
and anna i know at the tc obviously
you're going to be very concerned about
jobs and
they're making it clear today that green
trade spells green jobs but some people
working in fossil fuel industries might
say but i'm really worried about losing
my job i mean is there a balance that we
need to strike there
what we need to do is we need to future
proof the high carbon industries that we
already have so we've calculated that
there's about um six hundred thousand um
660 000 uh manufacturing and supply
chain jobs in the uk that depend on
um on on action to future proof these
industries on public and private
investment
and on trade deals that protect these
jobs from being offshored
so there's absolutely no either or we
just have to make a plan for how these
industries transition
to the net zero aligned business model
and we'd have to do it on time and we
have to have trade deals that protect
those jobs in the meantime
and tommy are you confident that kind of
transition is in place that we're on
track
no i'm not confident we're on track but
i agree very much with what anna was
saying if you look at the best possible
thing you could do for the climate in
this country right now is invest in
improving energy efficiency uh which
would cut bills create lots of jobs uh
and really help and that opportunity was
completely missed in the spring budget
for instance and in the energy security
strategy if you want to get off using
russian gas the quickest way you can do
it is to reduce the demand for it by
keeping build people's bills down your
energy efficiency and i don't need to
ask you what you think about that cause
i can see you nodding away there so we
will move on to the next topic if that's
all right and uh the numbers are pretty
astonishing one in six deaths in the
world are caused in part at least by
pollution and of those air pollution is
the biggest killer and tom these figures
really are extraordinary and perhaps
what's even more shocking is the fact
that they haven't really changed uh
since 2015. so why do you think that
such a big killer is not being tackled
more effectively
uh i wish i knew why because not only is
it awfully
bad for people and people's health
especially children especially anybody
who's got a problem like asthma and so
on but but much more importantly it
praises an enormous burden on an already
overstretched health service that we
don't deal with this problem in
particular the bit that we really need
to do uh in our cities especially as we
know the summer coming on we really do
need to speed up the
pace at which we take out the internal
combustion engine and replace it with
electric vehicles which don't create
that local urban pollution which is a
big source of the problem for people
and anna the report said that 90 of
pollution deaths occur in low and middle
income countries i mean more generally
speaking is it poor people who are
suffering the most
yes absolutely and uh we know that um
bad air quality disproportionately
affects uh working-class communities and
it also disproportionately affects even
in the uk also disproportionately um
affects um black and i think minority
communities as well
um but the
the the good thing that i would like to
say is that we can all do quite a lot on
this and it's not just political action
it's not just demanding action of our
political representatives it's not just
individual action but it's also action
in our workplaces where air pollution
affects everybody at work um on some
level and uh we should all be thinking
of ways that we can tackle that problem
for example by switching our workplaces
fleets to electric um cars where that's
possible
so so basically what you're saying anna
is that employers can make some really
sharp decisions that will protect their
employees
absolutely yes we've seen that happen at
royal mail for example they've committed
to a fully electric fleet by 2030
and they've got a really good process as
well with the postal workers union the
cwu where they're working out on a
localized level how to best arrange this
so that people are protected from the
risks associated with air pollution and
so that it works for the post users as
well
and tom interesting there that anna's
talking about you know companies
switching to electric fleets for example
and does that make you think this
problem could sort itself out in the
drive towards net zero as we move off
polluting industries as we move away
from polluting vehicles for example
that will
reduce pollution
well it will certainly reduce pollution
but i don't know
from the climate let alone for people's
health that we're going fast enough but
the thing i think we miss and anna was
right to point out what companies can do
and what people can do in their own
lives but we should be making much more
use of local government as a delivery
mechanism for improving air quality as
we found out during the pandemic local
government turned out to be a really
important part of being able to deal
with a sort of
crisis like this that's very dispersed
and different slightly
from area to area and i think we've got
a whole
sort of approach to this i think you
must do things if government's got to do
them it's always got to be national
government and i think we underestimate
the importance of local government
particularly when you've got to try to
get people to join in and
do bits themselves local government is
much better at getting people to do
things the national government is
interesting okay tom and anna we are out
of time but uh very interesting to get
your thoughts today thanks very much
indeed
so do stay with us coming up next we've
got the take with sophie ridge and
attorney general suella braverman
discusses the government's response to
the cost of living crisis that's coming
up next but from me that's it thanks for
watching and i'll see you next time
[Music]